[موسيقى]
لم يجد هؤلاء الناشطون المؤيدون للقضيه
الفلسطينيه سبيلا سوى محاوله الهروب من
قبضه قوات الامن التي منعتهم من تنظيم
فعاليه مؤيده للشعب الفلسطيني في ذكرى
النكبه
العنف والتوقيف طال الفتيات ايضا
المره الاولى فقد رفضت السلطات الالمانيه
مرارا منح تراخيصا لاقامه فعاليات مناصره
للشعب الفلسطيني تقول الشرطه الالمانيه ان
هذه التجمعات تدعو الى الكراهيه وتنكر حق
اسرائيل في الوجود فيرد الناشطون لانها
الذريعه التي تستخدمها الشرطه لالصاق تهمه
معاداه الساميه بهم
نائب رئيس منظمه الصوت اليهودي من اجل
السلام والعداله في الشرق الاوسط يرى ان
حريه الراي في المانيا لا يعتد بها عندما
يتعلق الامر بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
منظمه هي الوحيده التي سمح لها بالتجمع
مرور الوقت فيما يتعلق بالتظاهر في
المانيا تقدم المانيا نفسها كدوله
ديمقراطيه لكنها ليست كذلك هذا الاسبوع
فقط تم حظر العديد من المظاهرات الخاصه
بذكرى النكبه من قبل شرطه برلين
على الجانب الاخر تجمع شبان المان منعصر
للقضيه الفلسطينيه في برلين رغم رفض
السلطات تحيط بهم قوات الشرطه من كل مكان
نسعى منذ سنوات من اجل سلام عادل نحن هنا
من اجل ضمان حق التعبير والحديث سوف يتم
الاشاره الينا على اننا معادون لساميه
ولكن هذا جنون فنحن يهود لكننا سنبقى
متمسكين بضروره تحقيق العداله للفلسطينيين
ساحه هيرمان بلاتس ببرلين قبله مناصري
فلسطين فرضت عليها شرطه برلين طوقا امنيا
ومنعاه الناشطين الاقتراب منها
الحكومه الالمانيه تمتنع عن التعليق على
عدم منح التصاريح للناشطين لكنها تحاول
تقديم مقاربه غير مقنعه للناشطين بشان
كيفيه التعامل مع اسرائيل
الامر لا يتعلق بالتظاهر ضد سياسته
اسرائيل الاستيطانيه او السياسه
الاسرائيليه انما بالمظاهرات التي تنكر حق
اسرائيل بالوجود والمتظاهرين الذين يهتفون
بالموت لاسرائيل وينشرون خطاب الكراهيه
هنا يكون الامر قد وصل الى حد معاداه
الساميه وهو ما يعد جريمه في المانيا
اختلفوا كثيرا عن موقف البرلمان الالماني
لبوندستاغ الذي اصدر في وقت سابق قرارا
اعتبر فيه ان حركه مقاطعه اسرائيل معاديه
للساميه يقول بعض الالمان ان ذكرى المحرقه
تجري في شريان النظام الالماني برمته ويصف
سياسيون كثر الخيط الرفيع الفاصله بين
انتقاد اسرائيل ومعاداه الساميه بانه كاد
اي تلاشى لان اسرائيل جزء من الذاكره
الجمعيه لالمانيا برلين